we're gonna begin with this a dangerous
wildfire that broke out overnight in Los
Angeles it's threatening hundreds of
homes near the world-famous Getty Center
strong winds are spreading very fast a
fast growing fire that's burning along a
major freeway west of downtown the Los
Angeles Fire Department says these
flames have already burned 300 acres
several neighborhoods are under under
evacuation orders right now Carter Evans
is near the scene in Los Angeles so
Carter I guess the question is what are
the firefighters facing right now well
the good news is the wind seems to have
calmed down a bit so the firefighters
behind me you're just trying to keep
things at bay to give you an idea of
where we are we're just off the 405
freeway in Los Angeles up the side of
this mountain would be the Getty Center
and this entire mountain was on fire
just a few minutes ago but firefighters
have really managed to keep it from
spreading across this road here I want
to show you some video that was posted
on social media by a driver just a
little while ago one side of the 405 was
turned into a towering inferno now it's
prompted the Los Angeles Fire Department
to order mandatory evacuations in the
area already several evacuation centers
have been set up as well fire officials
are calling this a dynamic situation
that flames are being fanned by high
winds but again they do seem to have
calmed down just a bit now one of those
displaced from his home but the several
fires burning mirela is LA Lakers star
LeBron James he tweeted this morning
saying he had to evacuate his home
suddenly he's been driving around trying
to find a place to go with his family he
followed up later saying he finally
found a safe place but he is just one of
many who are evacuated out here tonight
and are going to have to deal with the
fallout from this fire again the good
news is it and if you look behind me you
can just see the hillside here is
smoldering the brush right here hasn't
burned yet so what firefighters are
trying to do they're trying to keep the
fire from catching this brush here and
then jumping over to the other side of
the poro five camping all right Carter
thank you those pictures from along the
405 are really frightening